so check this out check out lovesync
you're going to like this
sex that's a really weird way to start
off i'm just stalling right now hoping
she's in the mood for some horizontal
hustle
and i anybody who calls it horizontal
hustle should never get laid for the
rest of their life
you should never ever again know the
feel of a vagina
horizontal hustle ooping she's in the
mood for some horizontal hustle
and i'm just waiting for him to make the
first move so we can do the mattress
mambo
nice well she's doing a lot of mattress
mambo apparently
she doesn't look like the kind of girl
that usually have a problem getting to
do the horizontal
whatever hustle or the mattress mumbo
she's got an
open i'm pretty sure she's good to go
you're cleared for landing sir
i love her and i love him i'm just not
always sure she's ready to do some
dancing in the sheets
what is this supposed to be uh we'll
find out when i am
i've been shut down before you know i
don't believe it
here we go now right now i'm all sweaty
[Music]
eventually it leads us to stop trying as
often
well you're in luck because there's love
sync
i'm sorry thank you for pausing sure
when i know what happens it's not like
it never happens but it's very rare
how often do guys actually say no to sex
when they're like even when they're not
in the mood
like guys usually you'll just be like
all right i'll bang one out real quick
right like
well how else can you sell this product
though but the product is based on a lie
like yeah like most products if you're
not having sex
in any situation it's because the woman
at that time has decided she doesn't
want to have
the sex there's no like you know in a
relationship there's really no like
pressuring a man into sex like there's
times where guys aren't in the mood
but we are a little bit more
like flexible when it comes to that like
women will be like come on it's [ __ ]
like i've had that happen where i'm not
in the mood but you're like all right
yeah let's go real quick you know i mean
you go and you get it done
and you come back down and because then
you know they're happy they're good
you're good
everybody's good women are the ones that
usually are the ones that are like i'm
not in the mirror
and everybody has to be miserable for
the rest of the day um
but this isn't this is like she's
sitting there and abroad everything and
he's like
like no that doesn't happen a guy be
like all right i'll [ __ ] you but
i'm coming right back out here in like
eight minutes and i'm watching red zone
and then i'm gonna go agreed lovesync is
a device that lets you know when both of
you are in the mood for some
hippity-dippity
it's super simple all you have to do is
i'm never going to be in the mood for
any hippity dippity ever again after
this
of your bedsides and when you're feeling
a little randy
you just anonymously push the button
there's no risk of rejection
why does it need to be anonymous it's
there's only two people involved
how decent why do you need this who
needs this
who's this for how numb to human contact
are you trying to condition us to be
you're about to stick your genitals in
the other person's
genitals what is it why are you
why do you need to anonymously press a
button if they see it light up and it
wasn't me i know it was her
how about hey do you want to [ __ ]
it this is this is like
more of this hey let's let's like just
become less human
and not communicate what we like we've
already we've already become
so like obsessed
with our devices and our internet
and all this kind of [ __ ] that it's like
we're already becoming like
in it we have this inability to
communicate with one another why can't
you just ask and talk to people like
why is everybody so autistic why can't
people make eye contact anymore why
can't people just be normal
only one of you pushes the button
nothing happens
and your partner's none the wiser
oh okay so except you both of you would
have to push no no but
the other partner doesn't know unless
they also push it so they both have to
push it at the same time or you don't
know that the other one pushed it
so if i push like tinder so if i push a
button
and then i don't get any response then i
still know you're
not wanting to [ __ ] no no yeah well
so my point is though from what i'm
understanding here is like she pushes
the button
and it goes into some system but the
system doesn't notify both of them that
anything happened unless they both press
the button
this is stupid
[Music]
but if your partner's also ready for a
pants-off dance-off
they'll press their button the lovesync
technology combines these anonymous but
you just push the button right in front
of them like i don't even understand
wouldn't you be able to see it like
right wrong there
he's sitting right there and she's like
babe like why are you buzzing in like a
game show
wanna how about this just the thought
you [ __ ] weirdo
creeps why don't you just start sucking
his dick
i ladies if you're listening if you're
watching this out there i'm going to
give you a piece of
solid a plus advice and it will never go
wrong
if you're in a relationship with a man
and you want him to [ __ ] you
and he may not be in the mood or
whatever just suck his dick
just suck his no man can resist a dick
suck
a guy will [ __ ] you if you suck his dick
all right i've had women
like get me to [ __ ] them that i had no
interest in because they just started
sucking your dick
and you're like all right you like the
scene in good fellas when he's like oh
all right this is like that's all you
got to do
just like you don't need to buy a
[ __ ] 300 device
and sync it with your phone and add some
battery draining app that's going to run
in the background
and kill your phone and like ring up
your data
just suck his dick or not even suck his
dick just rub his dick a little bit
through the pants
done and recognizes that there is
consensus it lets you both know by
emitting a swirling glow from the
buttons
[Music]
pressing the button multiple times sets
a longer time period that you'd be down
for
bopping by the way she she says buttons
the way your brother does and i
hate her for it buttons buttons
buttons joe buddy two-person push-ups
it's amazing for those times where you
wouldn't mind being surprised
in the middle of the night which i
avoided in the past fear of waking the
beast
we surveyed couples across the globe and
over 50
said they would initiate more often if
they knew they wouldn't be rejected
by their partner left sink is perfect
for partners because
it alleviates sexual frustration now
you'll always know when you and your
significant no you know what alleviates
sexual frustration
a [ __ ] [ __ ] true
this is so stupid
so if you think love sync can help you
why not try it
back us today and get your love scene so
you're gonna be backing their
kickstarter
are you sure this isn't just a clip from
silicon valley nope
there's your kickstarter
their goal is 7 500. how much they got
so far can we see
we could always find out can we see the
the project see how they're doing
oh it's not even showing oh 442 back
21 000 for this
what
hey chyna if you're watching this over
on trovo
um i don't know what you're doing with
this whole slow bleed
just kind of letting like kind of
letting us slowly die
but chyna you have a real opportunity
here
america is like a dog that's been hit by
a car
and it's laying on the side of the road
and it's whining and it's crying
and it's slowly dying in the streets and
it's breathing is becoming more shallow
and it's like the dog is suffering the
dog is suffering
on the side of the road and china this
is your chance
to do something to do something humane
and just put us out of our misery once
and for all just
just do it just do it fall out style
just do it like again i i we don't want
to i don't want to lay
culturally on the side of the road
like just waiting to die or get hit by
they hit their goal they've shipped it
it's out it's
already out man please please
china